Dividamos 7,182 entre 42. La diferencia que
tenemos aquí es que ahora vamos a dividir
entre un número de dos dígitos, no un número de un
dígito, pero es la misma idea, de modo que decimos
¿cuántas veces cabe 42 en 7? Bueno en realidad
no cabe en el 7, así que agregamos un valor
posicional más. ¿Cuántas veces cabe 42 en 71?
Bueno, 42 cabe una vez en 71. Recuerda: al hacer
este proceso en el que decimos que 42 cabe en 71
una vez, lo que realmente estamos diciendo es:
42 cabe en 7,100 cien veces, porque estamos
poniendo este 1 en el lugar de las centenas. Pero
dejemos eso a un lado por un momento y centrémonos
en el proceso. De modo que 1 x 42 es 42, y ahora
restamos. Ahora es posible que puedas calcular
71 - 42 en tu cabeza sabiendo que 72 - 42 = 30,
así que 71 - 42 = 29. Pero también podríamos
hacerlo reagrupando, para reagrupar queremos
restar 2 de un 1. En realidad no podemos hacer
eso de una manera tradicional, así que tomemos
1 decena del 70 para que se convierta en 60
y sumaremos esa decena a la posición de las
unidades para que se convierta en 11, así que 11
- 2 es 9 y 6 - 4 es 2, y obtenemos 29. Y podemos
bajar el siguiente valor posicional, bajamos un 8.
Ahora esta es la parte artística. Cuando dividimos
entre un número de varios dígitos justo aquí.
Tenemos que estimar cuántas veces cabe 42 en 298,
y algunas veces puede implicar un poco de prueba y
error, así que realmente tenemos que calcularlo a
ojo, y si cometemos un error volver a intentarlo.
La forma en que sabremos si cometimos un error es
que si decimos que cabe 9 veces y multiplicamos
9 x 42 y obtenemos un número mayor que 298,
entonces nos pasamos, y si decimos que cabe
3 veces y multiplicamos 3 x 42 y obtenemos
un número aquí, y cuando restamos obtenemos
un número mayor que 42, también cometimos un
error y tenemos que ajustar hacia arriba. Bueno,
veamos si podemos calcularlo, así que esto es
aproximadamente 40 y esto es aproximadamente 300,
40 cabe en 300 las mismas veces que 4 cabe en 30,
por lo que serán aproximadamente 7. Veamos si eso
es correcto: 7 x 2 es 14, 7 x 4 es 28 + 1 es 29,
así que nos acercamos bastante. Fíjense que
294 es menor que 298, así que estamos bien,
y mi residuo es menor que 42, así que también
estamos bien. Ahora agreguemos otro valor
posicional, bajemos este 2, y aquí sólo nos
preguntamos ¿cuántas veces cabe 42 en 42?
Bueno, 42 cabe en 42 exactamente una vez: 1 x
42 es 42, y no tenemos residuos. Por fortuna,
este número se dividió exactamente:
7,182 ÷ 42 es exactamente igual a 171.